[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett right now at the
table of dim lighting we've got mr.
Steve pink we usually don't do this we
usually don't start with our guests but
we're in what is called a time crunch
and so we are just hitting the ground
running welcome Steve a director of
buddy system season 2 yeah thanks for
having me yeah we just wrapped I know
just like we frickin just wrapped just a
couple of days ago yeah and we literally
just walked off of the photo shoot they
call it the key art photo shoot yeah
we're still in character yeah I haven't
I haven't I haven't changed back into
link I'm still just blink I'm buddy
system season 2 link which is kind of
the that's the link that you know that's
the link I know you pretty much know a
link with a mustache that's all I know
so when I shave this thing off we're
going to hours we're gonna be complete
strangers and then we're gonna be and
when we go to the wrap party everyone's
just gonna be talking about how I look
different I might not shave the mustache
so after that because I don't want that
thing I have to talk to everybody about
right wow yeah you don't look as good
without the mustache that's not what I
want to hear right well they might not
say they could just get oh you could be
slightly worse because it would be more
generic like they might just say oh you
shaved off your moustache right no come
hey again and again and he shaved off
your moustache like a non conversation
conversation because they don't know
what to say they can't they can neither
say and it looks worse and if they say
oh and it looks so much well some people
might say and you look great but then
that also implies I've been looking
horrible right so this whole show it
does give people something which I don't
know I have something to talk about
which i think is I think giving people
something to talk about is a good thing
for a party I'm personally you know I'm
a as soon as we finish this I'm going to
a doctor's appointment because I'm
trying to figure out what's going on
with my throat I think it's just stress
I think we just overworked ourselves yes
and I think I'm coming down from it but
I'm going to see a professional before
we leave to go to New York just to make
sure that everything's okay but I'm
afraid of like party talk I'm afraid
that I'm gonna go to a party have a
party talk situation and lose my voice
if you shave your mustache all the
attention will be on you and I won't
have to talk about anything and people
just go to me and I just point at your
face I think you should shave it that's
my personal opinion
which ironically we've gotten very good
at that pointing in each other from not
speaking and communicating not that that
is is a major part of a buddy system
episode I'm also gonna take my
headphones off now so you don't need
them you're saying that doesn't mean I'm
disengaging from the conversation it
just means I mean I like what you got
going with the hat and the headphones
but mine is not really sitting really
well for me so mine are kind of drawing
my ears back in a weird way you don't
want it either I'm gonna try taking them
off now yeah you should well now that
you know how it sounds now you can be
there no I'm in charge of like keeping
you guys on on mic not necessarily
you can't self-regulate any more you'll
be back here no no well can we come up
with a hand signal that you can unleash
yeah yeah like bring it in bring this
okay it looks like bring it counting
money is what it looks like that's right
because I get paid every time I tell you
to bring it in I just thought it would
be you know it's funny we didn't have
that many times that meaning the chill
windows of opportunity to have like to
just talk when we were on set because so
we can talk about that but there were
there's certain moments when we have
like this flash in the conversational
pan with Steve pink yeah where I would
bradwick cinemates learn something about
the guy and be like mmm
we got a podcast that up yeah and then
we gave him no way out because we asked
you in front of everybody like right
before you're you're like all right is
everybody set you're about to call
action and we're like oh will you come
on our podcast yeah I didn't know we
didn't give you any out didn't you
didn't know although we were talking
about except the word know yeah I could
I have said no in front of everyone I
don't think I have that kind of glory
that would have been a bold move yeah
and not even like no one that would have
been a great set story for the whole
crew yeah you can listen this one time I
had these two guys making this show and
they asked the director to be on their
podcast and he said no just a freshness
and immediately afterward action no
action no no I don't do that great
and yeah well that's you know I perhaps
should have done that you know now that
Miss Rama ties Everett well because we
were I was saying like oh yeah I'd love
to be on their podcast and then I've you
know been in you know I've had an
anxiety attack ever since that moment to
my wife like why would I do that why
would I be in a podcast because you know
there are other people who I recognize
but it's the same dimly lit a Steve I do
like that and this is properly shaded oh
yeah yeah yeah I feel like there's
something some protection in that is
when Rhett is with you is that why you
wore your hat because you knew Steve was
gonna wear his hat yeah definitely I
don't even own one of these hats the
reason I wear my hat is because I've got
this going on which once you take my
man-bun office like cutting my testicles
off you know it's like then I've just
got this weird eunuch cut so you're
telling me that in normal life and your
normal look you don't have testicles
right I agree no when my hair goes up
it's like I don't want to keep going
with the phallic analogy but it's don't
it's like a penis well take a lot of
penises
take it back off one more time and just
look at Steve it's that the back is look
even further look past Steve there's a
thing happening for you my duck tale for
you audio only listeners which are the
superior version of this show you're not
missing anything except some weird back
but back head hair situation back head
hair situation
I remember we talked about in one break
we didn't have a lot of breaks I don't
want to complain about our about the
nature of our show but we I mean I'm
sure the three of us could sit down and
commiserate forever about how hard we
worked we could and and that's it was a
pleasure working so hard for you and
alongside you thanks likewise but at one
point we were talking about the classic
question of if you're stranded on a
deserted island mm-hmm
or if there's desert there is a desert
island and you can only take an
unlimited supply of one particular food
what would it be I don't know if that's
the classic question but that's the one
you answer yeah that's the one I cared
about and but you had to you insisted on
- I know this answer very well
I insist on - for some reason which
breaks the rule of the game right away
like right
the bat it makes the us challenge
whatever you answer it the thing that I
loved about it and the thing that one of
the many things I love about Steve that
I could tell when we talked it came up
in conversation but it wasn't like I
just posed the question to you and you
thought him an answer no this was
something you had thought about
previously I think it actually this is
something you were pitching to us maybe
which with all the pitching we do to
other people and like stumping people I
really enjoy when someone's really
thought about something thoroughly and
then they bring it up and we get put on
the spot hmm
but give it give us your your answer now
that I've built it up as being so well
thought out well like well like I said I
I cheat at the moment I make I propose
the idea right the concept only one
thing right yeah you can only have one
thing if you could eat if you could only
eat one I guess
type of food a category of food on a
desert island you're on a desert island
and you only had one category of food to
eat for the rest of my life mm-hmm what
would it be like would it be what would
it be cereal for me just because I love
cereal right and that's it you get
cereal and milk and that's it you're you
know for the best rule I'm on a desert
island and so I love peanut butter could
just be peanut butter it couldn't be
peanut butter spread upon anything that
I could spread it upon sure sure but
then you couldn't change it right so if
you went you know with a graham cracker
oh that's it although like I said I
since I cheat almost like the moment I
proposed the game then then I think you
could probably have not only not only
any type of cracker but you could also
have maybe any different kind of peanut
butter or even an almond butter what
about a buffet is a buffet a category of
food see I for some music yeah well I
get you know you know for in some
buffets sure because there's some
buffets which are just that thing that
everyone's like cottage cheese like
canned fruit and I love salad like a
like the biggest like Golden Corral like
everything right I'd have a go it's not
can you take a restaurant to a deserted
island what restaurant would you open on
a deserted island Golden Corral do you
even know what a Golden Corral I do only
because I just went to one for the first
time this year actually I went to the
one and I was both you know judgmental
and you know it's knobby and superior
about it and then massively and then
massively enjoyed it yeah it's I mean it
was like this is one of the best
experiences in my life yeah but you
can't you can't do it on I mean there
are people that we know from back home
in North Carolina who could go multiple
times a week I mean I can go I can go
once a year to a Golden Corral and then
Golden Corral doubt you know mm-hmm so
maybe it's not a good answer because I'd
have to eat it every day on the side
right that would be it
that would be it so even that's the
thing that's the kind of tricky and fun
thing about the game because even when
you say okay I'm gonna cheat and have
all this variety as my answer to the
game you switch once you start to really
consider it right then you feel limited
by it right even Golden Corral suddenly
it's not enough options right that's
interesting okay I still don't know your
answer mine is sushi and cheeseburgers
oh okay right because I want sushi I
want the fine you know cuz I like you
know I like the you know the I like the
freshness of you know fine cut finely
cut raw fish is that how you say it
sushi cut fish with rice and then
there's all the fun you know kind of
rice and fish combos that sushi provides
and then and then but then I'd be like
oh I'm really still hungry
I want something greasy and a guilty
feeling a guilty pleasure thank you yeah
yeah I don't want to be so refined I
want just some Chi I want to
cheeseburger and fries and a coke so
what I don't be aware though because I
mean I'm I'm I'm cracking open a whole
other can here but I mean if you're
gonna have only one cheeseburger you
should probably choose where it's from
to make sure it's exactly how you want
it and that's where would that be that's
the whole thing you know them itself
which I think it emerged as a more
difficult question to answer over the
last few years right with the Kraft
burger or whatever they were yeah all
right yes your category so you don't
know you but do you have that answer you
know what I would say whatever they
dropped off the c-130 like there was a
plane that dropped it off you know what
I mean like but if you could choose I
could choose I mean would it be in and
out would it be the steaks shake that
would be my yeah I haven't had a Shake
Shack is that all it's cracked up to be
it's been a long time since I had one
I remember enjoying it it got Lilly went
with a friend the other day and she came
back with a magnanimous report she did
where do they have Glendale homey I
would probably do Fault in and out but
I'd like to reserve my right to taste
Shake Shack and then revise my answer
right I love it good cheeseburger I
think I'd do five guys you would think
yeah and a lot of people would say pizza
cuz you might shift what's on the pizza
and you're like you got us why and if
you're talking about that category nest
and you don't want let me do go and
crawl buff a pizza is the one I would
choose because you've got a lot of
loopholes with the pizza you got a lot
of food groups from once and I went out
with a sushi that I mean you can
probably just swim off your deserted
island and like hand spear a fish and I
mean that's pretty much sushi yeah it's
gonna ruin a little bit that there are
all these fish swimming around junior
just eating raw fish right I'm
unnecessarily verd by a plane right I'm
unnecessarily giving away a category
yeah because I could say cheeseburgers
and then secretly be like and I'm gonna
catch some raw fish
yeah yeah it's like right it's almost
like saying I would like on my deserted
island to eat just saying sandwiches you
know then you realize oh that was a
little bit short-sighted about part
right as intrigued as I am by this
motivation I do think we do need to talk
about buddy system so I'm really right
let's do it
but before we do that we need to we need
to March it up Murch it up let's take a
short break and we're gonna where's that
merch where is it at link where's it
we're gonna talk about the good mythical
Summer Sale right
Oh right here's your night so we got 20%
25% on I'm a write-off all good mythical
morning classic good mythical morning
merch just for you Steve over at rent
lean accomplished store
look at this we're talking t-shirts
we're talking beanies we're talking
hoodies 25% off now Steve what do this
do you want because yet though you keep
25 or 25% off yeah I see what the
original price was there's no price tag
say that it's 20 okay why definitely the
I'm I like Navy okay these are my high
school colors by the way rhythm yeah
blue in Navy and orange yeah wild kids
it's like it's like Virginia is that
right yeah yeah
and then I wear my beanie a certain way
so I'm not sure that it this would work
we'll have to see I don't have a mirror
anything let's see if it would work I'm
trying on though just one try on the
merchant yeah you could try it on so he
needs to be kind of a tight straight
line and not too much top yeah well
there's a there's a gratuitous tag that
goes we encourage people to continue to
wear the tags because that's what's kids
are into now he can work I don't know
does it does is it that words it
straight across though and I it would be
with a little assistance if we gave you
a mirror which we don't sell you would
look great alright so that concludes our
promotion you're thoroughly convinced
25% off get that logo guys I don't know
if it's going anywhere but it's
commemorative its commemorative I think
it might be okay so I remember the first
conversation that we had right we had
that we had a meeting it's right in here
in this room over here in our office
because we had to decide who's gonna
direct our you know our baby yeah and we
act we wanted to have a meeting with you
for season one but you're unavailable on
another project at the time and so and
then it can't your name came back up or
like he'll never do it he'll never do it
but we should at least have the meeting
with him so we had that meeting and then
I remember you you you didn't a lot of
people you know you have a meeting with
him and you can kind of tell that they
did that like you know the 20 minutes
Kim before the meeting to kind of know
how to talk about right what they're
about to talk about but correct me if
I'm wrong you had watched the entire
first season I watched the first season
you know yeah what's the first season
that I read and beyond well watch other
stuff too oh yeah and then videos and
some sketches just well then it was
random right I watched the first season
as like what else is all these cats
about you know it's not just random
video or sketch so I did you know was I
just logged time because I couldn't
after a while it I couldn't figure out
like what logical order to watch things
in so I would just watch videos because
I remember saying to you yeah oh
that was awesome you're like that was
six years ago all right so yeah okay so
you know some things I watch you were
ashamed of that so yeah we don't do that
anymore so I watch some older stuff and
some newer stuff and and then you know
and then read the wiki that's what wiki
is how we round to portmanteau yes he is
extensive man that thing is out of
control
yeah I read the whole I don't remember
the portmanteau absolutes the whole
thing starts with that yeah someone
should look it up and first of all I'm
not sure I'm saying that word correctly
I'm necessary if I'm saying if I'm
pronouncing pronouncing it right but
internet Ament it says you're a
portmanteau of dot dot dot dot dot yeah
and I was surprised I was like I don't
know what that word is really and nurse
it means putting two words together
right is that right so I think I
probably looked it up prior to that
meeting but if since forgot forgotten I
do a lot well yeah was gonna ask you had
an assessment yeah I mean the thing that
I think it's hard to assess yourself and
when it comes to buddy system season one
I mean honestly one of the things we
were disappointed with was it it didn't
get enough attention from I'm not saying
we wanted like critical attention but I
guess I am saying that it is it I was
very curious what if someone who is
critical for a living
assess our show what they would say
about it and I would say that when you
came in you kind of you gave your take
on it and it was it was very I guess I
enjoyed it I enjoyed having someone that
I respected their work who took the time
to look at our stuff and then had
thoughts about it and who you assess our
style in a way that like when you're in
it and you live it and you just make it
up as you go along and you find yourself
creating stuff that you know you you can
never step out of yourself and assess
what you really think of what you've
done
so it's nice when someone that you
respect that you don't know I mean you
could have you could have said you could
have said anything that could've been
lip service but I could tell that like
you had actual thoughts about it and we
really appreciated that and you had good
ideas
well they build upon it and that was
that was I was that I probably mustered
although I could you know muster for
that meeting as I call these are all
them together in a half hour and Hawaii
because it's a lot to decide him in one
like thirty minute meeting say okay are
we gonna we're gonna get in bed together
creatively I don't remember I wasn't
ever that he creatively yes you know
it's quite a commitment talking about
what directors are dylon is sleeping
together and I'm just out in the cold I
guess it's a commitment the other way
too and I which would explain why you
actually watched our stuff you don't
want to just jump into a creative bed
with somebody with two guys and then
have to make their thing or direct it
you know it could be it could be really
bad well yeah situation could be bad but
I mean I think beyond you know whether
you know well yeah I guess I wouldn't go
to the meeting if I was like it's not be
actively my thing but also then you know
I'm always like I always feel like we
try to avoid a situation where you want
to kill the people you're working with
and if you don't like their stuff and
they don't like how you're how what what
you're about then you're just gonna try
and kill each other for most of the time
you're together which beyond the
creative process is just not not a wise
choice you know right but I feel like
maybe you can tell me what you feel I I
felt like it was always trying to be
deeply funny without trying too hard and
also be deeply interesting which is a
tough combination like you there's
there's plenty of stuff that's just so
funny and you just get it you know it's
just and a lot of the stuff that we did
the season and that you do is just kind
of like readily hilarious but then there
are other things that are readily
hilarious and also something that you
have to really kind of you know absorb
or when you absorb find that there's
other kind of levels to it and that was
what I liked most I was like oh yeah you
guys are trying to figure something out
I don't always know what it is but
you're you're light you like the ideas
and you want to explore well it's not
because we you know I kind of have I'm
of two minds about this because there's
the like there's the thing that I want
to believe which is like yeah I think
this is I think this is a legitimately
original approach to to comedy this is
an original like we like to maintain a
sense of originality and not have
anybody be to not be too referential I
mean nothing you know everything's remix
of course but to not be able to just
have people point out you guys are just
like this or just like that or your
accommodation of this or that so that
there's a sense of originality but then
I think that there's this other part of
my mind and I'm sure link has the same
thought which is just like when are
people are gonna figure out that we're
just posers you know I think every
professional and entertainment business
feels that way I feel like I'm posing
right now right exactly
you're like what are they gonna figure
out that I don't have any idea what I'm
doing or you know we kind of felt that
our entire career it's like when are
they gonna figure out that we actually
are just really good at making you think
that we know what we're doing right but
I think which is what I'm saying when
Steve came in with like a very
intellectual assessment like you really
thought about the way that we had made
the stuff we had made and I was like oh
we fooled him so no I'm like
specifically I remember you made you
made an observation of something about
how we would choose to make left turns
in things I can't remember exactly what
what you thought of it maybe you
remember yeah like it resonated with us
it was like we never thought about it
that way but yeah we do try to do that
yeah like the commitment to a deep dive
digression I guess is how I oh yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of cool but that is just
in a kind of an area of comedy that I've
always been interested in and people
have done in the past and when I was
super little that the things that I
thought was I would I what made me laugh
beyond the jokes like you'd see a scene
and it's really funny and then you laugh
and then the scene would take you to
another place which would not only make
you laugh but you'd realize you were
going down some rabbit hole of the
comedy you just enjoyed and now you're
being forced to enjoy it on another
level and then on another level all
within the same laughs kind of so like
Monty Python did that there was like a
famous pet store sketch where John
Cleese goes into a pet store and says I
think it's to Michael Palin that is
parrots dead and it's
strictly dead you know it's just like a
stiff hair like bangs and on the counter
and you know was trying to convince the
pet store owner that the the parrots
dead and the pet store owner refuses to
believe it's dead because you didn't
want to give the guy refund right oh
that at the end of that sketch turns
into a song because I believe and my
memory is vague on this cuz I know it's
been a long time but I believe the pet
store tries to sell him in return
instead of giving him a refund a half a
be like literally a half of half of a
honeybee half of like a honeybee which
turns you
yeah half a bee which turns into a song
entitled Eric the half of these cuz he
which which he took home that's the
point yeah right at that point it's a
song about a half a bee named Eric Eric
the half of II I believe and it's you
know all people listening this can check
my facts on this because it's been I
mean I was eight years old or nine years
old so but that's just what I remember
now they could have been totally two
different sketches and I confess I put
it in my head as something that was
connect hopefully not yeah hopefully not
but when I start when I saw you know
when I saw your work and I saw that you
would you know take these left turns and
then go down that road as far as
possible leaving behind anything you
might have set up to begin with to me
was just you know great right like the
bellybutton song I don't even know if he
watched that one but yeah I don't know
why we did it but it was like all right
if we're gonna add a second verse of
this song about two guys discovering in
in their late 30s that they have belly
buttons for the first time if we're
going to continue that songs through a
second verse well something else needs
to happen which involves selling coal
plants door-to-door to children right
and I don't you know it's like if you
look at point a and point B it's like
how on earth could this happen but it's
like you know okay we got them along for
the ride as long as they don't click
away so it's weird how I think there's
two factors that brought us there it was
it was one you don't want people to
click away so you can't retread you
can't sing a chorus again the chorus has
to be new lyrics every time but then
also I did I just don't like I don't
like knowing that the audience feels
like they know they know where this is
going and then it does hmm I like I'm
expecting it to go somewhere and then
never does and I think that's true of
hopefully every episode mm-hmm season
two is this like it when that opening
scene is not really gonna be you I don't
know how you could figure out what the
closing scene is gonna be based on the
opening scene there's it's just even
with the setup you don't really know
what the overall punchline is gonna be
but when I remember one of the things
that but even that just to close the
loop on that when you this was the
conversation we were having the first
time we met it was like okay yeah and
but then you went you started talking
about a movie that was like it don't
talk about that a second okay
specifically with this cuz I back to
that same conversation mm-hmm one of the
things you said that we didn't realize
again having somebody that you respect
and who has done a lot of work in this
field that we kind of feel like again
like we're kind of like posing our way
into and I think that's a what that's
how anybody who's kind of come up on
YouTube feels because there still is
this from a critical standpoint in sort
of industry standpoint there is this is
this actually legitimate you know
there's still this struggle for
legitimacy but when you analyzed it and
you said you take these left turns but
your characters are always kind of just
like shrugging shrugging those left
turns off you never make a big deal out
of it's like you face this thing without
any sort of fanfare at all it's just
seems so oh this is natural that we
would suddenly be here and this is where
we would be going and I think that
there's a number of reasons mostly just
just instinct and it's unintentional
that we did I think most of it was just
like oh we just think this is really
funny and it'll be it wasn't really well
thought out to be like oh and then when
we go there we won't have much of a
reaction to it it was all hard about it
but it wasn't I don't know that I was
calculus yeah that particular element
wasn't calculus was until a 'td but then
we go back and look at everything we've
done really oh you're right we always
approach things in that way gloss over
the absurd right the characters aren't
fazed by the increasing absurdities that
you that you write surround yourself
with all right or any situation and the
increasingly absurd situation you put
yourself in doesn't necessarily have
your correspondingly effect your
character in some way like you're
willing to accept the new circumstance
like like instantaneous yeah and we
always want that new circumstance to
come from a very relatable circumstance
which I think that which is what link
you were about to talk about which is
when you begin
tell the story about what is the movie
the discreet charm of the bourgeoisie
yes Louie boom well yeah yeah yeah and
you just because you were talking about
left turns and that has some of the
greatest left turns and movies ever and
I was amazed when I saw that movie again
I don't know what I was doing watching
this movie when I was you know I guess
in high school so by that time I was
like oh I'm gonna be cool and
intellectual so I'm gonna watch it cool
and intellectual things that are above
my you know intellectual abilities and
but what happened what was the
declaration
well there's it's about a you know it's
about this kind of like this a stock
recei of characters like these this like
I think they're I think they're related
in some way I think there's a husband
and wife or this collection of
aristocrats who go on this crazy journey
and there's these constant digressions
like I think the one I told you about
was when once again I hope my memory
serves me correctly because I'm sure now
that I'm saying out loud on a podcast
it's not even right I'm which is
actually okay with me too I guess
because if that's what I've it only
matters what we what we think well what
the application yeah what the
application was but I think there at
dinner and some waiter comes up and
starts telling them a story and you know
you cut away to that waiter story and
you think okay this is gonna be like a
two minute story and it's gonna have a
little beginning middle and end and then
he's gonna you know we're gonna cut back
to our main characters but you don't for
like a I think almost a how it seemed
like a half-hour like to the point where
you're in another journey and tire on an
another journey entirely and then you're
I was kind of shocked when we returned
to the restaurant right where the waiter
says oh and thank you for listening to
my story and walks off to take their
order and then you're back with our main
care and when you told us that story we
don't even have to communicate about
things like this like we know we love
that kind of thing so when you're
telling that story we're both already
thinking okay that's happening in an
episode and when you're dealing with a
22 minute comedy we're basically already
thinking okay so we're gonna have an
episode where someone's story becomes
the episode and that's where the whole
right Lucy episode episode six came from
which is I don't know you know and we
haven't seen any post we haven't we
haven't been in the editing Bay yes so
actually we saw a little sequence yeah
we didn't know if we needed to pick up
shot right is inevitably my favorite up
so but I don't you know I'm I'm
withholding judgment at this point I
know it's and we didn't need to pick up
the shot
no I didn't think so so there we go we
saw that thing you didn't see it you
didn't see the little sequins no but I
know I pretty excited of rude of me not
to show you but when I heard that
everyone was happy with it I was like
well I'm not gonna care and then the
others because then the other the other
similar idea that we had which was can
we do an episode where we don't speak to
each other and when we told Michael and
Siebert that am I gonna see her who were
our head writers on the show and Sharon
kind of along with us ran in the writers
room you could kind of see the fear in
their eyes when we said we want to do
sure an episode where we don't speak to
each other and of course it's not
necessarily completely not speaking to
each other but it takes not speaking to
each other about as far as you can take
yeah in both cases like it becomes many
things right and it does any many things
it actually became many things that we
then had to rewrite because they were
too many things and you and Stevie
busted it and you were like guys act 3
that whole thing right Wisby yeah that's
not that can't be a thing of the many
things that can be it that is one it
can't be and I think we can say why we
did there it was a it was a parody of
American Ninja Warrior
and some other reality competition shows
which which incidentally and it was but
I like it with a crazy twist and weird
constraints oh yeah so what and it's not
man this is one of those things where we
throw ideas up on a board and then when
episode ideas get filled in and we see
that we've got two ideas that we wanted
to do left over and there's one episode
left we put them into the same episode
that's all that what happened yeah that
wasn't we want to have a reality show
parody of like American Ninja Warrior
and we want to have an episode we don't
speak to each other so we originally put
them together which incidentally then
when we were shooting the the you know
our flashback episode every morning in
santa clarita we passed the ultimate
Beastmaster yeah we did a huge thing was
which was another one of
references the Netflix sliced alone
produced you know American Ninja Warrior
ripoff so what you're saying is we could
have shot we could it's on their actual
doll head to sit down yeah yeah yeah I
think we would have been fined because
you almost got fine just when I around
yes I did almost got fined and it wasn't
I almost was fined and it was not funny
it wasn't like I was almost on a horse
because there were horses around it was
it was the modern version of a horse in
that it was a gator it was a local work
very expensive mama - that was like how
much is one of the you know divert him
from the fine with doctor Gator how much
one of those things run you like that
cause you're backing away slowly yeah
he's like 20 grand wow that's an
expensive equipment yes I was almost my
mom my mom has one of those really she's
a high roller we're at the movie ranch
basically you're not allowed to wander
and wander is the technical term wasn't
that's not just a word I'm using to
describe it it's what it says on the
side that's right you cannot wander and
me I needed to scout out that location
it's got the location of the opening
shot of that you know of that flashback
and so I wandered I just didn't I just I
had to go and wander and I didn't really
think about it wasn't like I was like oh
I'm gonna be you know I'm gonna be
contrary and you know and wander and
would be rebellious and you know flaunt
flaunt font file out it out it flout the
rules is that I don't think that's
flaunt I think is what I'm looking for
yeah the rules I wasn't that I was just
we were working quickly and I needed to
go yeah so I did and there was a you
know I come down the mountain and
there's a guy with that classic you're
in trouble smile you know the classic
like semi fine you yeah yeah like that
he didn't have to say anything because
he's got the smile on his face that says
you're in trouble and I'm like what am I
like this is what like what you got you
got off right well there was a 24 hour
discussion about it actually because he
I was super night I was like you know I
just you know I was like hey listen I'm
sorry like right off the bat I'm coming
down the mountain and I'm like I am
sorry
I I know I'm not supposed to be
wandering and that you know that I'm not
supposed to be wondering cuz you're here
to catch me you caught me right yeah
like I don't know how you caught me but
clearly
you know I mean I guess I coulda said
hey I got permission but there was no
radio from locations to then you know so
they knew when I never seen this is a
big source of revenue this is like a
small-town cop catching it this is like
a SpeedTree was $100 yeah right that's
not small yeah it's $100 cash for
walking you know for 100 yards yeah off
the the you know the designated area and
that's on you because it was on the call
sheet
yes and on the bathroom door yeah was
everywhere I did read it on the call
sheet I don't know why I don't usually
read the call sheet but I read that and
I was like kind of laughed to myself and
I was like how would what like that
would ever happen a wonder right and you
know we own what you know where you guys
do remember in the river bed I don't
know how much we can describe and with
that very last job we all ran to the
riverbed yeah that was almost a company
fine
that was like an N mass wander oh yeah
because we were losing light and the
location we chose was not going to work
as it was 200 it was on it was it was we
were losing lighting it was like yeah
look the place we had we had chosen for
that was under trees guys all under the
canopies yeah couldn't do it so we're
like oh and so then we just ran over to
the riverbed and there's a massive
scramble and then I don't know you guys
were me you guys were changing because
you had to get in a change and right I
went over to the same guy I hope his
name's Pete because that's my memory and
I said we need to wander over there at
the creek bridge and he was like look
like looks like you already have oops
and I was like can I apologize for that
I really do I'm not trying again I'm
tell me again how much I can we still
talk about that yeah you know I you got
out of it twice though well then this
time I yeah cuz the first time yes I got
out of it twice the first time I could
see being like the hey I'm just gonna
make this all in good fun did not work
because I was saying it was 24 hours
that you know they came to me later and
said you still might be fine because I
was trying to be all jocular like when I
came to my oh I'm so sorry I yeah I
wandered that's all just a joke isn't it
I'm going back to our look at so sorry
that did not fly with that guy because
he went on to maybe find me and so then
the second approach was to be very
serious about it very serious and
professional listen I'm sorry and
penitent yeah I was
no joking one knee both knee the whole
thing like not hey I'm gonna make light
of this stupid rule but hey aren't we
just friends and isn't there's a funny
rule that's it's not right it's not
funny and so then yes I worked him in
that way and that worked I was like
listen both of them yeah sorry I cut you
no no no both of them great shots right
yes you got that establishing shot that
was the first wonder when you got the
establishing right no or you were
looking for yeah yeah that's where you
guys come down though that's one of the
biggest challenge yeah with that big big
giant lens yeah with the Klatte the
classic yeah the biggest shot of the
whole thing probably tonight and then
you got the night well I mean it let's
see the creek bed closer the creek bed
closer was really good because that was
an that was like a act to close their
type thing cuz it yeah because it was
turned out to be a location that looks
really crazy and almost like on another
planet
yes very Craig Star Trek yes very Star
Trek you like yeah and so then when you
guys revealed yourselves yeah yeah we're
up the creek right am i right it's true
a very dry creek now one of the things
that we were talking about was you know
we don't Lincoln I carpooled together
out to our location in Pomona where we
shot most of our stuff out in Pomona and
so we would we talk on the way I talk on
the way back and you know it kind of hit
us a few weeks in that we were like now
what's different than season one because
we it I feel like we're working harder
let's feel like I just feel a lot more
tired I'm I remember I remember coming
home in season one even though we were
working 12-hour days and telling my wife
I was like this acting thing is nice
this is these guys got it easy I was
like this acting thing is like I was
really nervous about it but you know I'm
not saying necessarily good at it but
I'm saying it's not it's not it doesn't
really tire out tire out unless you're
doing like a revenant thing and you're
like right DiCaprio like jumping off
cliffs and stuff like that but we did
none of right but we were trying to
figure out what is it what is it about
the season we're like well maybe it's
you know
maybe this was pretty ambitious for 33
days yeah you know so season 129 day
shoot 14 minute episodes going to 22
minute episodes we're going up at least
50% in content but we're also I think
scenes per minute
you know scenes per episode or whatever
way up like just the pacing and that was
something that came you know that was a
kind of Michael and si pushing us to
keep the pacing up more so than we did
in season 1 it's growth great all this
is great for the final product but
extremely ambitious for the parameters
we had in terms of time and money right
yeah and you you there's no way you
could have fully appreciated what we
were throwing you to who started this
thing I did not fully appreciate but you
although you didn't mention it several
times did you this is what I would see
this is what I would hear in your voice
and see on your face there was a you
would say things like now this is really
ambitious but then I can hear in your
voice you're like but of course I mean
we're gonna get more days we're gonna
get more money you believed that that
was gonna happen I did sorry sorry about
yeah well maybe not necessarily more
days but I didn't actually realize that
not a single minute of overtime would be
allowed and that's not an exaggeration
either when I say oh now a minute I
actually mean really hardcore not a
single minute now I actually as you
could tell rebelled against that greatly
for the first week or two because I
didn't actually couldn't conceive of a
world where one single minute of
overtime could be the collapse of the
season and so I was like oh I have to
adjust because I have no there is no
failsafe I even an extra 20 minutes say
would be in a no buffer enjoyable no
buffer and so so I do adjust to that I
think but I I what the thing that I
always keep in mind when I'm doing
anything and certainly with this show is
we have to achieve it I know it's some
kind of an obvious thing to say we have
to achieve it because no one's going to
know nor care what we faced nor tried
you know what we tried what what goals
we set once it's in once it starts
getting cut and it turns into episodes
no one cares we could say we literally
listened
everything took place on the moon we
actually were the first you know movie
production television production to
actually fly to the moon create an
atmosphere on the moon and then shoot a
comedy series on the moon and then we
came back people would be like oh great
it's yeah it's not so funny right you
know so Jake it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter you have to achieve it
and and so then you know I just I just
always keep that in mind so that we can
you know we can try and you know create
something great every day and I thought
that you guys I know can you compliment
kids can we compliment you on it your
own podcast is that Italy without
seeming obsequious no one no one's done
it before you guys are super prepared
you know like you got out it's good you
drove together because there's no I mean
we you guys were putting away two and
three pages in an hour sometimes you
know and that's just not a thing I
experienced and other shoots and other
shows because you know you haven't
either have a little bit more time or
whatever but if you guys didn't actually
know everything you were gonna do pretty
much all the time
nothing we wouldn't have made it and so
that's really a testament to your hard
work I mean I was I was amazed and
that's why I kept saying the last couple
there's like there they're gonna bail us
out of this one we have 10 seconds
they're gonna bail don't worry that we
got this as long as I put up the cameras
then we'll get something because because
you guys were ready for it and that was
that wasn't I was impressed by that yes
that you were ready for it sometimes it
was it was fun to know that we just had
ten minutes and we were gonna try to get
two setups so we had one take at this
thing from each setup so then it was
like you know because I mean it's to
like just to stay so aggressively on
points like okay I'm not gonna I can't
fill up a line and I want to hit these
marks type thing right that was fun a
few times that was fun
right I mean you actually couldn't flub
a line like that's how that we were in
situations where right we got it you
actually couldn't [ __ ] what I think that
once we talked about that all the time I
I think this is this is just rooted in
being in being executive producers and
creators on the show and kind of feeling
the weight of like when we think when we
say
there's no overtime it's like we're
saying there's no overtime write it so
it's not us against then we have to kind
of put ourselves on on both sides of the
line and so that we always say don't be
the problem be the solution right well I
think a lot a lot of actors you know
just almost instinctively it's like
they're gonna they're gonna be the
problem right that's there's so many you
SuperDuper do alloted and how does they
have to do good work they have to own
they have to do their thing really well
and there's a natural give-and-take they
should and you know if you're really
great at that you've earned the right to
create a ripple effect of problems that
from as producers you start to
appreciate how it ripples through
everything and then it cost X number of
dollars and so we know that intimately
so I it's not that I'm saying that I
would think normal actors would be
annoying I haven't worked with that many
but yeah we never we never feel like
weird we're actors we're something else
that then we have we have to act to pull
it off as part of acting because we have
to do it yeah right it's I I feel like
that's like whoa we got to make this
well we got to be in it that means we
have to act as well okay we got to
figure out how to do that but we
definitely can't be the source of it's
not that we don't want to act no no what
we want to act in it but we want but
we're never fully actors I think with
the pressure of time we were always
thinking about three other things at the
same time five on the product how
quickly do I need to get this don't be
the problem the whole thing the whole
thing is what is in view most of the
time yeah and acting is a part of it
right finishing all the time is a part
of it
sure but you have to be good sports too
because there were times where you know
cuz actors you know do you need space to
kind of do it right and do it well right
yeah I mean despite the fact that you
had your executive producer hats on
sometimes it just was just like life
isn't fair guys like life isn't fair to
any of us you know we have to just put
it away so that was good that you guys
were good sports about it cuz there's
still something that's important and you
want to do it well and it should be
funny or it should be good and you don't
and it also can't be wasted you know
not work right you know in it I mean
part of the fun of acting is discover as
discovery and sometimes that doesn't
happen until you're actually doing it I
mean I mean we're so calculated and we
worked so hard at every effort at every
step that we were intimately acquainted
and we had certain expectations of
ourselves and each other and everybody
else in the scene and even you and so
it's more of we got to execute what we
expect but there's some there's a lot of
fun and discovering something like a
different angle or how to tie two shots
together or a nuance to an accent or you
know or just perform in a different way
like oh this is this this is a lot
funnier than we thought because I'm
crying now no I didn't think I was gonna
be crying or I thought crying would be
funny but now it's not so I think they
were you know because it was so
aggressive I certainly missed that
experience of like figuring it out
because what would happen like if I'm to
overgeneralize the thing we would work
really hard on a scene you get it done
get it done and then immediately like
immediate be like alright next scene and
then we would go and it would you would
you know you'd physically move over just
the the actors and producers in you and
we would rehearse and that was a fun
moment but it was it was very high
pressure because he didn't it wasn't
much time allotted for it but the
rehearsal was the time when you figure
out you block it out where you gonna
step where you gonna walk what are you
gonna say how are we gonna say it how
we're we're saying the lines and we're
seeing who laughs at what in the room
but we're not even given a full
performance yet we're given because you
want to save it you give like a half
performance but you got to give enough
to like have proof of concept or that
something make sure something is not
broken or needs to be fixed and then but
it's when everybody's making decisions
like DP is making lighting decisions
mood decisions you're making all these
cut angle camera decisions directorial
decisions we're blocking all this stuff
everybody's making all these
instantaneous decisions
pop up all at once and it's like okay
and we need to be done with it but it is
it so that we can just shoot it right
but it but that is a fun moment because
I'm trying to think of an example but
you don't really know if it's gonna work
it's like that's a big moment or when
you have someone come in it's like
Garrett Morris a legend comes in from
the first season of Saturday Night Live
and like I knew this you know I have
images this guy in my brain from like
the earliest memories of comedy it's
like this guy's a part of it yeah and
then all of a sudden he strolls onto the
set and first time you see him in action
is this rehearsal but it's like all
right is he going 50% is he going 90%
and this is true of everybody and so
then we're kind of we are you're
assessing like alright what's he gonna
give us is he I mean is it gonna be
great is it gonna be horrible is it
gonna be somewhere in the middle so
you're like discovering all that knowing
that you know 20 minutes later after
you've rehearsed they bring in the
cameras and they set up the lights and
everything else and the props were set
and everything you're gonna do it no
matter what it's like it's like you've
jumped off the cliff and you better hope
that squirrel suit on firls but for you
I mean it was this was this is all the
the whole process is obviously something
that you've been involved in for a long
time but the limitations how much did we
mess it up for you the limitations that
you you usually don't have these
limitations like because you you you did
us you did us a solid and saying yes
your work on this based on your level
experience in the in the size of the
projects you've done before so you
talked a little bit about like
recognizing those those limitations and
like how that's is that change the way
you think about directing off oh yeah I
mean to me well the main thing I'll I
had to remember is to continue it was to
have fun like we'd be in a situation
where was like you know I have to change
the way my prime I've changed the way I
work in order to make sure that we
execute properly and then I'd get all
mad at myself or mad at everyone and
then I'd have to realize that this is
deeply crazy what we're doing and
therefore it should only be fun all the
time otherwise wise to even stand where
I'm standing so I had that was first
like okay just remember that this is all
should be kind of fun I mean on a
technical level I I started thinking
about lenses differently you know
because what is the best frame if you
don't get two of them you know if you
don't get two sizes what's the best
frame in any particular situation I know
it's not me this is where this is what
I'm about to see is like the cure for
insomnia for most of your listeners but
I'm excited to me well lenses are a big
thing you know like what you know how
you know when you get to cover things
and you get when you know you have you
know say you know three hours to shoot a
three page scene versus 45 minutes say
you know how best to cover it and and
you know what are the ways in which you
know when you have that much time you
can shoot it many many ways and you get
lots of coverage and get lots of main
goals and you know so I had to figure
out how to kind of efficiently shoot
something and still make it good and
still make it funny or at least funny in
the lens you guys were you guys were
funny and great and so I had to figure
out you know you know how to best
capture it because you can't be too wide
you can't be too tight it has to kind of
you have to tell the story visually so
that I learned I'd say I learned some
stuff you know I learned some stuff you
know gags are gags though to me that
didn't change you could probably see my
like I always got a lot more you know I
don't know whatever intense when we were
doing gags as opposed to scenes because
see when you guys are you know when the
floor is yours and you guys are doing
character work and being funny and it's
in dialogue you can cover that a budget
of ways it's gonna be great right when
you're doing gags are really specific I
need very specific shots if you don't
have those specific shots the gags don't
work right period so I would always get
more kind of intense you probably notice
when we were shooting guys cuz they have
to should be shopping and we had a lot
of them you had a lot of 14,000 I think
I think fourteen fourteen hundred and
seventy gags and it was great but that
was great so those have to be shot well
I didn't you know those just have to be
shot well so speaking of which shall we
talk about the Texas which yes because
to me that's that's like that's my
favorite that's like the vanity bumper
sticker of buddy system season two is
Texas which Texas we take the vows out
and you make it into a
about a vanity license plate yeah right
yes
CCH you can put the tea in there yeah
you could I have time after what I just
said for a second say please cut that
all out
I don't know well because it seems very
boring doesn't it no no the mythical
beasts man you name the lens
oh they care so boring I think they care
about it really yeah they're all they're
all creative minded people yeah well
then there may be an aspiring directors
many of them and current directors ooh
we got it all baby all right
I'd never heard the term Texas switch
until you said it four thousand times
but it's our fault
cuz it's it does a lot of prop gags
right so it's explain it okay so the
Texas with me again cuz I still don't
understand well then there's not
remember we there's also the Hollywood
at in which is a yeah which is a kind of
variation of the Texas switch do you
think let's use this specific example as
a case study do you remember a Texas
switch that we can talk about we can
talk about any of them I don't care
hmm well yeah so okay Texas which we've
any scene we had one uh this this isn't
one of the situations where we had it we
had a gag we were trying to get with the
soup right so we've got the box that has
the food in it and I bring it in I
didn't think that's the one we ever
wanted to talk about though and I do my
I just because it was so hard as well
but I treat it very right you know
roughly and we set it down you open it
up and it's a perfectly steaming hot
bowl of soup right liquid in a bowl that
can't sustain being flipped around in a
cardboard box
I come in with an empty cardboard box
set it down Texas which bring in the one
with the with the soup in it and open it
up
that's the Texas switch that's right but
it just means that you keep rolling but
then in the Edit it can mean anything it
means you cut to another shot yeah right
you cut to another shot and then you
when you cut back the thing that you
wanted switched in what's like it's I
guess in like a theatrical setting
it's like hey look at me over here while
some stagehand over here replaces mine
with his and now there's blood in that
it's like a visual slide in hand if you
were a yeah and then we had to Hollywood
in the soup right which is also a Texas
switch you know I'm a little bit I'm not
someone out there have to kind of
clarify because there is hollywooding
something in what it's a janky way to
like or like a like the non-technical
way to get something in its place right
right like that could be a like idea to
you when you've got someone just holding
her doubts but notice you're gonna put
you're gonna let a grip hold the bounce
are you gonna let are you gonna put her
on a c-stand right so if the grip is
holding the bounce there hollywooding it
in that's what I always thought because
I think I learned that I've been in
Hollywood in Hollywood you can afford to
just have a person hold that as opposed
to prop it up against something right
but in Texas you got to switch it out
right it's a it's it's so Hollywood
Hollywood in something is a broad term
but Texas which is a is a narrower term
which we used many times I agree I prop
for us yeah and Hollywood it in has too
many syllables and it also is not as fun
to say as Texas which right chance which
has a very clear like you know idea
behind it right which everyone gets
instantly like you get what that is
let's do that you know right yes but now
the real fun starts I mean we're gonna
have a wrap party you know just a little
bit you know and then you're gonna get
in there and in the editing Bay yeah
very soon I looked at episode 2 today oh
you did almost my notes almost all my no
my notes are being done episode two
right now
all right well tell us because alright
it's fine if you say this because our
expectation whenever we see first edits
and we try to like we try to protect who
sees it so that we both don't see it at
the same time so someone can have a
preserved first look at something that's
further along is that how you do it yeah
I got you won't look at it at the same
time we we try to ideally now somebody
wants to have a fresh perspective yeah
okay to be like okay I thought this let
me see if he thinks this but we're used
to first cuts of anything there being
that
let down like oh I we feel disappointed
we've never been encouraged by a first
cut of any sketch music vid so it's okay
if you tell us that we're always like
mmm how did you actually feel well I
have that problem too
like I'll say like what was the point of
any of this you know but you know but
that's not but it's not personal right
it's like anything I've ever seen
yeah you know I'll make a sandwich and
feel that way you know I'll make a
sandwich I'll look at my sandwich and
I'll say well that's not in my you know
like my idea of this whole operation was
that some perfect thing was gonna emerge
and now it's just a sandwich so can
somebody Texas which in a better sample
yeah like you have to get past that and
and yeah so you have that's all just
yeah that's all just stuff like in your
head so you have to so what happens how
much of it you saw a majority episode
early enjoyed episode 2 I thought it was
really really funny and first I looked
to make sure that I got all the shots I
need to make it you know like I live in
fear of that right oh we better have
this shot because to me this shot is
what's gonna be crucial to mm-hm you
know making it good so I I'm out with
the editor I'm like good I'm I was like
go there go there go there I want to
let's just stream I just oh you were in
you are over show yeah yeah I went over
there and I just said I want to see all
these beats and I want to see what shots
I have just to see if these after seeing
the cut like you sat there and watched
yeah then I was like I want to know that
we have all these crucial shots - that
to me will make it 40,000 times funnier
and when most of those shots by God I
felt I felt good about that and then
poof you know performance is good and it
didn't make you know because I'm like
does this make sense to this do is the
Michael McDonald episode no no this is
this is the Glenn episode yeah okay you
know like with that crazy day when we
had 14 seconds to shoot that big set
piece at the end because that can work
right now like yeah how is that that's
the whole point of that that's the whole
big deal like if that doesn't work the
episode oh yeah but yes that was great I
was like let's go - I was like watch the
unseen first oh you didn't work
backwards watch the senior most nervous
about first yeah and then like there are
things that really work I don't know wow
I can't really say things right you're
not supposed to say things you can you
can indicate so that we know the diner
can I say diner yeah okay so that scene
is yeah that whole sequence from the
moment you enter the diner to that end
and then where you go that was wrong oh
yes tremendous that was it that was a
difficult day yes difficult day getting
what we needed yes it was true yeah it
was tremendously difficult and it is
commendeth the basement assessments
amazing
oh yeah mazing yeah that's amazing it's
it's it's yeah it's it's extraordinary
Wow it's extraordinary in the diner
itself as a is kind of the whole set up
to that is pretty extraordinary - what
about my pants joke is that still in yes
that's you cut that yeah no no no I'm
fond of that I didn't cut it and we're
not gonna we're gonna be short are we
good are we good on that episodes good
on time yeah I mean I've most of them
are long that's actually closest that
episode is closest to time okay so yeah
if you cut a lot then you'll be short
okay that's closest because that was the
thing that was the thing I was worried
about because you know our ad Jill kept
coming back and saying dude this is all
just too ambitious we're not gonna make
our days you got a guy you guys got to
cut more stuff and so you know Michael
and Seibert would go and make proposed
cuts and pages and pages and pages
continue to come out of the script as we
move along and we just kept thinking and
we can't be too short but okay we're not
no you most of the episodes are probably
long okay which is great yeah I mean in
that way and I'm so excited by the way I
mean it's these are proper episodes
versus season one was just like
webisodes that made up a movie which was
I'm proud of what it is but as an
experience for the audience I'm super I
mean we got well what do you predict as
your favorite episode I mean certainly
the one the one we talked about the one
that might be your favorite episode is
certainly up there episode 7 yeah but I
like the big six yeah that's six yeah
six is is up there people are gonna love
it because it's such a such a left turn
it's such a I mean it's it's crazy
different I mean it's it's a period
piece yeah yeah but the well you're not
talking to each other that one has this
interesting that's pretty I mean where
it goes is so it just exponential leaps
like the
exponential yeah especially you know
like the to me what made what made me
think maybe it was gonna be my favorite
episode is when the character Dylan
proposed it makes that proposal he comes
out of the bathroom and it's like what
hold on wait what you talk about a left
turn right he's like okay I see this in
a way that not only no one else in the
whole universe could see but certainly
not the audience and and I see it very
clearly and that's gonna be the next
move and that's a great move that I tend
to forget about the music cuz it was
like but I mean that reggae thing we
shot on the last day looks so great yeah
I mean it's that's gonna be that's gonna
be cool yeah my hope is that when you
when you watch an episode one of those I
think it's I want people to feel like
when they finish watching an episode
they can they think back to the
beginning of the episode and it feels
like how we felt when we were shooting
like whenever we were shooting it was
like I remember what we shot at the
beginning of this day and I it doesn't
feel like the same day because we're
shooting so much and like we're working
so hard but even from a viewing
experience I think story wise that'll
translate it's like at the end of an
episode they'll think about the first of
the episode and be like that can't be
the same episode yeah and then they'll
be like I remember there was a song like
in like the middle of the episode but
that feels like a different episode to
it's like right yeah I think we take
people on a a great journey adventure
and I'm interested to see how the
characters that you guys created how
they evolved over the eight episodes
yeah yeah in terms of especially because
we block shot the hole yeah yeah like
what your characters believed at the
beginning and what your characters
believed at the end I trust the
varieties I trust the writing to from an
IT standpoint it was it was difficult to
plug back in like we shot all the scenes
in the dining room so it's like the call
sheet would be like episode 1 episode 4
episode 8 episode 4 8 1 and we shoot it
in that order
yep but I mean as much as we we do
change yeah
I think you change we do change likely
but at least our accidents don't change
coz then that would have been really bad
except for that one day Oh Oh new
character on the fly oh yeah that was
that you weren't there but you're always
getting changed yes good move it was a
good move I mean it's good to have
people here I mean here's here's the the
the story we both read I both had
characters that we were playing
independently that we're basically going
to be cut together at a certain sequence
and we kind of conceptualized the
character that I played and then yours
where I wasn't in the room for that I
wasn't in the room when you
conceptualize the Cajun guy but I was
other than gentleman we thought I
thought it was supposed to be a Southern
gentleman we and we saw that they were
different and used to be a Cajun guy
they weren't but then when we rehearsed
it like the more that you were the Cajun
guy I was like I feel like this is
messing with my mind I can't be here so
I left I couldn't listen to you doing
your your character anymore because it
was messing with my character so then I
went off the whole time you were
shooting it and I was like we're Herzing
the freaking Southern gentleman
meanwhile I didn't look like a Southern
gentleman they made me look amazing and
very funny you never let that character
never left these and that's a lesson
that was a lesson learned that I should
have I should have assessed that the
moment of north east coast in the north
east coast that's right like once you
put once you put on hair and makeup
costume like that's the moment like you
got to reassess everything in the mirror
and that was a mistake I made I'll own
that but I think the thing was so then I
was off for her Cena Southern gentleman
and then I show up after you left I knew
in my heart of hearts that what I that I
didn't think it was I thought it was too
close but I wasn't willing to say
anything because I didn't want to be the
problem and then steeped you weren't
there so Stevie and Steve were over at
the at the monitor with their backs
turned to me watching I'm watching them
watch me off monitor out of the corner
of my eyes so I'm I'm performing to the
right of lens and over here I can see
their backs you know something's coming
yeah maybe in Steve
cbs-tv was the one who called yeah so
ask oh my god she's and she's learned
how to she knows she knows when she can
come in and correct correct it carries
it yes didn't make a big that was a bold
new right it was the last day but the
two of you conferred and you were like
the characters are too similar they
sound too similar and I was like well
they're from the same place they knew
each other years back please accept that
leave yeah and then you were like yeah
he doesn't look like he talks and you
guys are talking about and I was like
alright so I mean I have no clicked in a
mirror if we had time I'd have been like
alright give me 30 minutes let me go in
front of a mirror again yeah so then I
just did some different stuff on Cameron
I was like it's fantastic okay yeah I
mean it it wasn't the most pivotal thing
in such a crazy episode that I'm not
concerned about it right and I but I
think the takeaway the main takeaway was
you got people and you put in place to
be able to redirect and override and
shape something and you got to trust
those people and that's what we hired
you for and you more than earned that
trust after you know a few days of
working together so then by the last day
it was like I just wanted to be able to
pull my weight and take the direction
but I never questioned whether you guys
were right and you know we got long
standing track record with Stevie and
that certainly helped but I mean even if
if it was you saying that just alone it
was like I would have totally trusted
but I was like okay I can't blow this
I've got to change this character
entirely how many characters did you do
do you know I just lost commentators but
we did that we discovered that I had 58
costume changes in link had 60 costume
changes so and it's so at least at least
20% of those were different carries yeah
and it has eight episodes of television
and which is just stupid it's just him
and yeah so I don't know how many III
feel like I kind of exhausted my a bit
my accent ability the Cajun accent is
really I mean it was it was like it was
again it was I was going off of what I'd
seen on Swamp People it wasn't really
Cajun there wasn't any French in there
it was like well I don't know cuz that
wasn't there it was like let me out of
here cuz they don't wanted to mess me
yeah you were just kind of like I'm off
the ledge on this one you know yeah it
was just like what you look you what a
few root words that kept going back to
you yeah you just cracked and I like
that because was the end of the shoot
and I'm like okay that you know because
all of them were really cohesive you
know just like okay this is good because
it's completely it's it's completely
cracked open this is all going it should
go and then we immediately ran a hair
makeup and we turned into 80s hair metal
between well we know that comfort zone
yeah yeah for sure
well I'm gonna have to cut this short
guys cuz I got to go to the doctor
figure out what's wrong with me and if
I'm dying or not not not to uh let's
hope that I believe it is not yes or
there's a row yeah let's just tell us
that the wrap party yeah and
everything's well I might not be able to
speak I might be on vocal rest of the
rob party right bring a sign I'll bring
a sign bring so much and you can do this
you know are you doing the must what's
gonna happen are you gonna help him out
and shave and then that will ready just
point out and be like he was gonna shave
that talked about that what size shoe
are you gonna shave your mustache yes
there you go
but is the last thing would the mustache
this is it
yeah within an hour it's gonna be gone
and I'll have my wife back but that's a
wife I met lash oh well
man it was a privilege to work with you
like this is like link said we would
have enjoyed to be able to kind of stop
and reflect and just carry on a
friendship throughout even if I did but
it was very much work work work work
work just like Rihanna but it was
totally worth it and it was it still was
a great experience but it was it was
tough it's nice to me and I am exhausted
and now the friendship begins right
sorry it's nice that you're saying that
up that we're friends when you said that
to me in the trailer I was shocked you
know that you were like we consider you
a friend I'm like oh man that's a big
moment just snuck up on me because I was
saying tomorrow when you go through a
near-death experience together I mean
the best way to that's the thing but
yeah I said to my wife in preparation
you know I was like I don't know I miss
a on this podcast and all that and I
said because I don't think we've had
like this longer conversation ever
like our longest conversation prior to
this one was what you mentioned before
is when we met right yep got to talk for
30 minutes yeah and then that was that
was it and then yeah I think we had the
desert island thing and then we know
this we had the car thing you told me
about your car alright that was nice I
was like wow this the subject matter is
not that interesting but the fact that
we're actually talking yeah that was
nice so I'm happy to let's talk about
the car when you come back oh yes
because our friendship will only be
conducted on a pike right that's good no
no we this is a form of stopping and
celebrating and I you know I am trying
to like you said you try to be aware and
I am wrapping this up because I know you
got to go to the doctor just leave we'll
keep talking I can tell that's what's in
your eyes yeah right I actually went
around the bases again after he said
let's wrap it up so that's on me stop it
and celebrating I feel like this is a
component of that to reflect on what we
made together and it's important and
like the wrap party it's important we're
gonna go with everybody who we made this
thing with and you know you if it's the
last time you see some of those people
hopefully it won't be but it's like at
least you you we commemorated it that's
right yeah that's right that's what
we're gonna do so that's what you said
up but I'm never gonna see no friendship
will continue as well about working
relation thanks for having me it's great
fun thanks for thanks for listening
we're not gonna have another wrap-up
other than this we're just gonna toast
here it is come back next week for
another ear biscuit
[Music]